people of the internet retro recontour
here and welcome
back to harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban i know it's been a while guys i
promised you you all have been asking
for it you've been waiting when am i
going to bring back the let's plays it
is finally time guys it's finally time i
know it's been a while and i apologize
for that i never meant to take this long
of a break but hey you know what
happened we started getting a ton of
hogwarts legacy news
uh the game that we have been talking
about for months years at this point we
finally started getting info on it and
i'm stuck right here i cannot get by i
don't know why this is happening but
yeah it's it's been a while it came to
hogwarts the sky lightened to a dazzling
opaline white and the muddy grounds were
hidden beneath a blanket of soft snow
inside the castle there was a buzz of
christmas in the air
marred only by worries over professor
snape's imminent potions class well we
got the grap horn horn but last time i
checked we were still missing some of
the other ingredients
we better go and find them before we go
to snape's class then
so just to catch everyone up i did go
back and see where exactly did we leave
off so we escaped the dungeons and then
we went ahead and ended the day and so
here is what we have on tap for today i
need to collect ingredients for the
antidote to uncommon poisons that is our
next mission and as you guys know from
the past episodes when it comes to this
game if i just stand around for very
you think hagrid long help there you go
there you go if you stand around for
long enough hermione and ron will not
let you stay in one place they will very
quickly tell you what you need to go uh
get what you need to
where you need to go basically so let's
go ahead and read this note here i just
want to make sure
uh if we spot this remember all last
scene near the stone circle in the
grounds if found please return to this
notice board honestly it doesn't seem
like it's as big a deal to find those as
it has been in past games mainly because
of the fact that i think you only get
house points when you find them at least
that's all i've gotten so far when you
uh find one of the items
all right so according to hermione we
need to
malfoy instead of you harry ron i always
have to
have to stop and listen to see if what
they're saying is actually important uh
but yeah so i think according to
hermione we need to head down to uh and
visit hagrid and he might be able to
point us in the right direction at least
in terms of this specific item that
we're looking for so
of course i don't remember any oh my
gosh why am i getting stuck on
everything today
uh but yeah i'm not gonna remember
anything about where to go so north wing
there that's gonna take us back into the
common room we don't want to do that i
think we want to go right here to the
7th floor corridor and then make our way
down
so that's going to put us here and then
we need to get to the grand staircase
which is
i believe it's this way here
let's see just keep going through here
yep grand staircase there we go nailed
it
all right so
i don't think they had a fast travel in
this game maybe we'll unlock it at some
point but i believe right now we have to
do everything by
actually walking oh wait why did it do
that
come on i'm right here
oh my goodness the controls
the controls i still can't believe that
this game even as old as it is i mean it
was 2004. i just kind of took note of
that when it first uh when i first
booted it up here before i started
playing again
2004 guys was the release for this game
and they did not have
where you could change the direction of
the camera it is it is inverted controls
for horizontal it's the most bizarre
thing
it is the most bizarre thing i don't
know if it was like that in the other
versions as well this is the gamecube
version obviously it's so weird to me
how i feel like the items are much less
interactive in this game
compared to like chamber of secrets
where you can just quite literally
blast just about everything with a spell
throughout the castle and it will react
but let's see who do we have here is
that lupine
how's it going dude can we talk to him
i'm feeling a lot better thanks
you haven't seen professor snape have
you
he has something for me
ah i wonder what it could be nope
haven't seen him though
all right i think we can just go on
outside the castle right now
and let's see if we can make our way to
hagrid's hut man it feels kind of weird
doing this again guys i gotta be honest
with you i'm not used to uh
having the sort of impromptu chats like
we used to on this
most of the videos that i have here on
youtube are of course you know highly
edited
and so it gives me a chance to really
kind of prep what i'm gonna say but it's
kind of nice to switch back into the
conversational mode here and i think
this is actually yep there it is there's
the remembrall let's go
that's right it didn't say entrance hall
it said it was uh
outside on the grounds
all right so where in the world
is hagrid's hut shouldn't it be down
this way somewhere
and the snow it's throwing me off
[Music]
what is that over there
we really need to collect some fire
seeds oh here we go there's hagrid
hello hagrid
how's it going i gotta tell you i just
got a letter from
the committee for the disposal of
dangerous creatures no way dude
investigating the complaint against
buckbeak made by lucius malfoy
still i shouldn't bother you with that
we have to find buckbeat still stuck on
those fire seeds
on the far side of the castle you'll
have to freeze it to get the seeds
though
burning bush on the far side of the
castle you'll have to freeze it to get
the seeds i mean is this it over here
and then hermione just said we have to
find buckbeak so i'm confused now
do we actually need buckbeak to solve
this
part of the mission or do we have like
two things to do here
nope they're still saying collect
ingredients can we actually
let's see though can i walk over here
and actually hop on buck beak right now
though
you're kind of crazy if so even if we
find some cheeseburgers how are we going
to get the camera paces off
oh my goodness
oh it's right i have to bow i didn't bow
buck week i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
can we can i actually like
bow to you here oh there we go
[Music]
okay sorry about that
sorry see malfoy
it's no special treatment
oh yes here we go dude
press and hold b to fly all right is
this
the bush over here
no it was just a random
all right can i dismount right here oh
that's awesome
i guess you could just fly him all
across the grounds
what do we have here spiders
oh my gosh why is it so hard to hit
these things
there you go just lock on
doesn't seem like that's doing anything
oh yeah i forgot bees how you uh
change to different characters i may
want to change up my spells though let
me just remind myself here of what all
we have with harry so we've got fopindo
which is knockback jinx expelliarmus
and i guess that's it huh
that's all that we have with harry let's
see about hermione here
actually let's check ron too
and you know what now that i think about
it i think can we yeah we can just check
them all right here so hermione knows
repairo expelliarmus
glacius and then flopindo as well
uh ron let's see the one different one
he has is lumos duo uh one lighting
charm conjures a focused beam from the
almost duo though wait what
i'm sure it explained that like i don't
know three four months ago whenever it
was that i
played this game last but
yeah it's so weird how when you get
closer to this over here that
it kind of vanishes so oh harry harry
was still over there let's see if
buckwheat's still over there too
just make our way back over oh buckwheat
is all right so i think we probably need
to uh hop on buck beak again
and then hagrid said the catch
eggard said the far side of the castle
right
on those cheese purples under those
bushes how do you think we getting them
out of there
are they wet under those bushes
i don't think that's our mission right
now i think
i think we need to focus on the fire
seeds right so let's go back over here
to buck beak now you want to talk about
staying true to canon how about that the
fact they make you bow to buckwheat each
time
that is a nice touch right there
really nice touch
all right let's hop on buckbeak here and
see if we can't find the uh
find the fire seats he said on the far
side of the castle there isn't enough
room to dismount move tomorrow well i
don't want to dismount i want to
actually yeah here we go
all right
okay there's another spot right here
that does not look like fire seeds
[Music]
dang they get the music too
makes for a pretty epic moment here
far side of the castle though i mean the
castle's huge
he said burning bush
the burning bush where is it harry
all right here's another little uh
beacon of light here
i don't know what those beacons
represent i mean there's been oh
wait
this looks like something important
oh i don't think we could dismount there
okay let's hop off right here
and we'll go over there and see what
that was
i mean it kind of looked like i
definitely saw something red over there
i don't know if it was fire seeds or not
but
what oh wait this is maybe this is it
this is the burning
i wouldn't say it's a bush but we've got
a burning tree here oh wait and then we
need hermione right
please tell me that she came along
somehow
please tell me that she came along i
don't see them anywhere near
oh my goodness they're like literally
trying to run to catch up with him
what
oh man there's got to be a way that she
can hop on buckwheat too right
did i totally just mess that up there
all right well it wasn't it wasn't too
far but
ooh you know what i should probably go
up this way though if we find some
cheese purples how are we going to get
the carrot pieces off them
one step at a time ron one step at a
time we got this
it's running freezing don't you know who
you're dealing with here oh and here
comes harry harry you could have just
stayed there dude
stay there and lead the way
you gotta love the seasonal weather
though
another nice touch
oh man it's supposed to catch spilling
is this the right way though
i don't think this is the right way
oh no the castle's so big
let's see what's over there nope
if harry would have just stayed okay
wait i do remember flying by that right
there
going this way
oh should i go that way yeah let's go
this way
even though i'm not 100 it might be
might be over there but hopefully we'll
end up in the same spot here
got a little bit of a fetch quest here
oh my gosh what just happened to the
camera right there no okay wait yes yes
this is it
this is it and there's poor buck beak
still sitting over there just waiting
just waiting like why did you take me
all the way over here and then just
totally abandoned me
what's that noise
i think this is where we can get fire oh
do you now
all right
whoa there we go
one just one more that's it
all right you can move the camera yeah i
know but i can't move it
in the way that i want to move it
all right so let's see what shows up
next here we got the fire seeds now we
need to
go to the right page first collect
ingredients for the antidote to uncommon
oh man it doesn't tell us what the other
one is one by one
okay i think though those other items
that were showing up on the
map i'm sure he can help us
go back to hagrid again
okay now hermione can ride but can we
all is there a way for all of us to hop
on here
come on harry go on ron join me
oh goodness they're gonna have to run to
catch up
all right so i think all of those little
uh beacons on them on the uh
kind of over world as we fly around
those probably are
indicating where the ingredients are
located
[Music]
and we definitely had one over there
close to hagrid but
actually couldn't figure out exactly
what to do with him okay so there's
there's one right here let's go ahead
and land buckweek here
i think this one we just castle pendo on
them right
looks like the cornish pixies i don't
know if they're needed for this or not
but
let us find out
can i like walk out over there
not sure let's try it
nope
definitely not
oh my goodness are you serious we get
treated to a loading screen for going in
the water wow
oh my goodness and it spawns me all the
way back here
oh jeez guys if that's not a sign of the
times i don't know what is that is crazy
and i wonder if it if i totally lost the
fire seats too okay no so you've still
got the fire seeds we've got the
grab horn horn which we got that from uh
before so
now let's go ahead and go back and see
if we can find the other items she did
mention hagrid again
i don't know if it's necessary that we
go talk to him or if we can just go to
one of those spots and
hopefully get exactly what we need but i
didn't get a chance because i decided to
jump in the water even if we find some
cheeseburgers how are we going to get
the carapaces off them
carapaces
i always pronounced it carapace i don't
know if that's a british
and uh american thing or if i've just
always been saying it wrong entirely
possible
carapace is how i've always said it but
what did ron say carapace
all right let's just talk to hagrid
again
billy wiggs okay
let's talk to hagrid maybe he'll have an
idea you want billy wiggs yes he'll have
to catch him first you might want to see
if buckbeak will do you a favor but be
careful with him now
ah
okay might want to see a buck we could
so bug week is necessary
for the billy wig so let's go ahead and
bow here
and hermione's gonna take lead i don't
know if we need the glacier spell again
but i'll just stick with her for now
all right so i don't think
i'm not even sure what the billy wigs
are i don't think it's that over there i
think it's these things over here
they're kind of flying and maybe
buckwheat just has to fly
fly through them here
hopefully we don't crash though
okay nope nothing happened right there
come on
dude you have to be like right on
it all right third time's the charm here
we go
[Music]
yes okay two out of three right there
nice
[Music]
no don't land buckwheat we gotta keep
you in the
air oh just above me no
all right let's turn it around turn it
around
[Music]
there we go nice all right three
now the other item has got to be this
over here
so i guess you should probably go talk
to hagrid one more time and let him sort
of tell us
how exactly we need to get that item
all right go ahead dismount buckbeak
thank you for your help there appreciate
it appreciate it
all right how's it going hagrid
what you're doing standing jabbering
under me for go on run along i'm sure
there are more interesting things to do
no we need your help
cheers purples
you can go looking for him near the
venomous tentacular yup but you want
something to lure him out with first
what's something i lure them out with
like what
shouldn't you be in class right now no
we shouldn't
something to lure them out with
okay i mean is that that's not bug week
is it
i should probably go ahead and bring him
over there just in case
i don't think we need him for this but i
don't want to have to walk all the way
back over here in case we do
so let's go ahead and let's see go on
we'll get the bow again right there
something to lure them out
i wonder if we have like a potion or
something that we can use
maybe some kind of item
all right it's really not that far but
still don't want to have to backtrack if
we can avoid it
all right
oh can't dismount there let's back up
back up back up
there we go right there all right i
wonder if it's the spiders maybe it's
something to do with the spiders luring
them out
okay he said next to the venomous
tentaculas but you'll need something to
lure them out
what's that noise
no i don't want to freeze
aren't those buckbeak purples under
those bushes yes how do you think we
getting them out of there i do not know
wait maybe this one this one is like
active right here
what in the world
oh wait wait wait there's a light over
here
where'd it go
okay maybe it's ron maybe ron has
something special to do
lumos
maybe shining the light
makes them leave
oh oh my goodness it actually does dude
oh my goodness it actually does
now what though
can i just pick him up now
nope apparently not
all right that light keeps popping up
over here maybe i'm supposed to like
lure them
over here
let's go
buck beak's right there hermione what
are you talking about
okay well we we got them to move
do they follow the light i guess they
follow the light
this way
maybe you have to lure it over here to
the venomous like see there's that light
again over there
maybe we have to lure all of them out
first let's try that
not close enough
dude this is so weird
this is so weird like what exactly what
is hermione doing
what is happening here man
this is the most bizarre mission
they're both doing it now
what the heck
is that a hint of some kind
oh come over here
like see there's that light but then
when i go over there it goes away
i don't understand
[Music]
i feel like this venomous spentacular
right here like this one's
active and a little angry like maybe if
i get it over here it'll eat it
and give me something else
right there
oh my gosh yes dude
okay talk about bizarre though
like why doesn't this one work you know
that one just doesn't care
that one does not care you have to come
over here to this one and then what is
that mysterious light
what is it doing
it's so
just deceiving all right there's another
one
are you kidding me it's directly under
bucky
there we go
all right here you go follow me follow
me
follow me to your death unfortunately
most unfortunately
all right a little bit further
right there be good
there we go nice we have all the just
purple carapaces we need
all right is that everything do we have
everything we need now
[Music]
yes go to potions class to mix the
antidote to uncommon poisons all right
nicely done guys
wow did that take us way too long
much longer than it should have you know
what we should probably take
i bet buck week will be a lot faster
and we might as well have hermione be
the one to arrive first since she'd be
the most likely to be on time
of the three of them so
all right hermione let's turn here
we really should be going no no no don't
dismount don't dismount i wanted to fly
back
and now we have to bow again
come on buckbeak we literally just bowed
can i not just hop back on
all right let's hold b see if it will
work right here
should we go to potions class there we
go there we go the controls they're so
wonky come on
i don't want to dismount
i'm holding b nothing's happening there
isn't enough room okay okay wait there
we go yes
yes there we go all right
all that and we could have definitely
ran back by now
a hundred percent we could have ran back
by now she's gonna try and land right in
the courtyard here
will this work can we dismount here oh
no there isn't enough room
about right here
are you serious
all that work and i'm actually gonna
have to oh wait there we go there we go
there we go
nice
all right you'll find your way back buck
beak right
you'll find your way back
poor harry and rondo they're gonna have
to make it on their own here
wait a second are we
are we trapped inside this courtyard
what no way
can i not just hop over right there
can we go through here oh my goodness
that is so weird
that is so weird so this whole area
is it completely enclosed
i don't believe this
i don't believe this man how is this
completely enclosed right here
all right fine i guess we have to get
back on buck beak and fly out
which means we have to bow again guys
as much as i appreciate the attention to
detail with the cannon that is oh
there's harry and ron oh wait wait wait
wait wait can i just switch to one of
them
hold on let's try this
oh no i don't wanna
i wanna land i wanna dismount
and then i want to switch and now i'm
just completely stuck here
come on come on come on come on this
mount dismount
[Music]
there you go dismount
all right then we'll switch to harry
who's just
magically they finally got over to us
here
let's see if this works oh yes let's go
now let's just go back into the entrance
hall
boom that's how you do it right there
exactly how they drew it up guys
i'm sure that is exactly how they wanted
that little section to go right there
all right let's head down to potions
and now we can mix this uh potion that
we are
what did it call it again here i think
it said something about
uncommon poisons the antidote to
uncommon poisons i can't even remember
why we're making this potion
but hey we're just rolling with it right
now all right into the dungeons we go
looking for professor snape
and the potions classroom
all right here we go we got slytherin
nearby but there's potions right there
let's go on in
see if it kicks in the cutscene here and
as you can see yep here we go combined
to form the antidote to uncommon poisons
which can be administered to cure such
things as the venomous bite of a doxy
now
i would like you to gather together the
following ingredients in time for our
gosh we gotta gather more flying
seahorses
doxie eggs toasted dragonfly thoraxes
and
fairy wings
he looks surprised
the girding potion
so wait do we even get the potion that
we just gathered all the ingredients for
you
or was it literally just to trigger the
cutscene
oh my goodness
can we go
let me check my inventory i think i
think it's literally just like
we have the wigan weld okay which
replenishes lost stamina
i think that's the same one ron has
and now looks like we do not have
hermione in our party she's gone
all right and i think she said we're
supposed to go to charms class now so
let's head to charms class shall we
since it appears that gathering those
ingredients was a complete waste of time
back to the entrance hall we go
all right let's make our way up to
charms
and i do not remember which floor it's
on
so let's see if the uh
see if it tells us here in the
tin the charms class on the second floor
ah love it
love it see nice and simple there charms
class on the second floor
so now we have to make our way back
through here
man i know i say this in like every
episode but seriously every time i play
one of these old harry potter games
it just reminds me of how
amazing it's going to be to play a
modern harry potter game
set and oh i shouldn't say harry potter
game but a modern
video game set in the wizarding world
where you can just freely roam hogwarts
professor dumbledore has ordered us to
stand guard on the grand staircase i
just i can't wait to see what flip
wick's going to there we go i just want
to go to charms
i mean just with the quality of life
changes from
2004 to 2022 in terms of loading in
terms of the visuals in the game in
terms of how it's going to feel when it
plays
i mean it's going to be and just an
incredible incredible leap
since
i mean
the last two harry potter games were not
that great definitely hallows part one
and part two
the best games in the whole harry potter
series honestly have been the lego games
most likely
and those you know are not graphical
powerhouses and you can kind of free
roam in those but it's not like a true
open world action rpg which is what
we're getting with hogwarts legacy and
man i cannot wait okay can we not open
this without hermione okay good i didn't
know if it needed alvin or not wizard
card let's
going to you go know i love the wizard
cards you've completed the quidditch
card set harry's endurance has increased
nice
all right let's go back to the
[Music]
oh man see if i can remember where it is
here
i think it's this one right here folio
universitus
all right and it said we completed the
quidditch set
so sippy and the owl jocelyn
wadcock
1911 to present
leopoldina smithwick
1829 to 1910 first british witch to
referee a quidditch match okay so she'll
be alive during the hogwarts legacy time
frame
1891. roderick wait hold on
18. okay now she wouldn't be at hogwarts
i was about to say would she be at
hogwarts no
uh roderick plumpton
oh he was two years old in 1890 seeker
for england quidditch team or i guess
one because he was okay he was born in
1889 yeah
yeah for some reason i was thinking 1891
but yeah hogwarts legacy
pretty likely is going to start
september 1st 1890 or at least that's
when we're going to start attending
school in the game holds british record
for fastest capture of snitch during
game three and a half seconds and then
barbarous bragg
introduced the golden snidget into
quidditch in 1269
changing the face of the game forever
there he is right there
there he is ladies and gentlemen all
right so those are all the quidditch
cards we've got that one complete
and now i believe we're ready to head
into the charms classroom here
hold on not over there
yeah just around here i think is the
charms classroom hello everyone are we
not late actually are we on time let's
go which is why the carpe retractable
what's up
it allows you to seize and pull objects
within your direct line of sight towards
you
sorry interesting
harp retractum i think that's what he
called it
just kind of how they're using accio now
in the hogwarts legacy game to retrieve
the carpe retractum spellbook
yeah carpe retractum
that might be
one of those video game only spells that
they made just for the game which which
were canon by the way
uh jk rowling had to approve them all
or at least i guess they got kind of a
blanket approval i don't know if she
actually looked at every single one but
yeah the video game spells were
officially considered canon
but
i i'm trying to remember i don't
remember that one in anywhere outside of
the video game i could totally be wrong
but
carpe retractum pull and hold r to
target an opponent and then cast your
spell
wait what that's an opponent
what am i supposed to be shooting
lasius
i have no idea so i'm just gonna run
can we not just go in here
nope blue male potion
[Music]
i think it may actually be the ice
here we go
oh wait okay so hold on the ice froze it
and made it stop
see then do i blast it with lupindo
it just keeps right on going
all right let's
maybe just hold down the freeze for a
bit see if anything happens
oh the other one keeps hitting me
come on ron harry do something
all right so if you
they're they're blasting it yeah nothing
is happening
all right let's switch to harry
or i guess ron's the only other one who
has a
oh no wait i think harry has uh it's
bellyarmis right
goodness
keep out of the way no hold on i'm
atretix bellyarmist this thing
terry's go-to spell you know
even though it behaves in this game
not at all how it is in the actual
you really hurt oh no
what is going on what am i supposed to
do with this thing
okay why won't they shoot it at
me i'm not feeling too good
oh that one actually finally charged but
is it ron
it's got to be something with the freeze
it's gotta be right
okay you freeze it right there hold on i
better use wig and weld or we're gonna
be in trouble
hey hermione has
let's see knock back jinx knocks objects
and creatures backwards
repairo mending charm fixes broken
objects
disarming charm oh so hermione knows
that one too
blendish has lost stamina do i have to
actually yeah
[Music]
oh my goodness it takes her forever to
pull this out
my goodness finally
wow that's worse than like dark souls
man trying to drink your estus flask you
gotta be kidding me hermione
uh i mean we'll throw on repairo just to
try i don't think
yeah i don't think that's going to do
anything
oh wait harry is like completely down
right now it's not good
too bad hermione doesn't know alamoura
yet actually even if she did i don't
think it would help
oh wow plenty of wigan weld though
see does harry stay down
oh he is dude he is totally still down
can i not revive him or something
i don't think we can all right it's got
to be oh he just jumped up
i have no idea why he just up jumped up
but he just jumped up
uh ron's about to go down to
one lighting charm conjures
like okay hold on guys there's got to be
something in the game
carp retract them and it was saying
something about whole art which i'm
holding
the right trigger
see if they show up in the folio brew
tie here
oh my goodness you mean i can't just
look at them
is there a flaming torch in here hinky
punk
i mean
i don't think that's what this is but
it's probably the closest thing
pixie red cap
oh my gosh guys
what are we supposed to do with these
things
what are we supposed to do i can just
feel you guys now even though you're
watching this much later you're not
watching this live i can just i i can
already feel the comments
of the frustration of people watching
this right now
for the people who know exactly what to
do here
like i said it's i feel like it's gotta
be something with the the glacier spell
because of the fact that
i mean it very clearly freezes there
maybe i just didn't shoot it enough wait
did i did i get that one i think i did
he doesn't give you enough of an
indication that it's actually working
there we go did we get it
okay but now what oh my gosh there's
another one
i'm just gonna destroy as many of them
as i can oh are you serious
and now the door just magically unlocks
oh i see i think that's like poor game
design because there's not enough
of a visual indication
you know i don't need them to yell hey
it's working but like there needs to be
some sort of visual element to let you
know that like it's
it's weakening or it's like actually
having an effect i better use wigan weld
on harry here
so let's go ahead and he only has two
actually
but yeah it's just like
it's so weird the game really doesn't do
anything to let you know that hey this
is correct this is actually what you're
supposed to be doing
all right that actually doesn't even
refill him all the way but i'm still
gonna switch back to this bellyarmis
here
ron is almost down too but
at this point let's just stick with uh
we'll stay on hermione
she seems to be the most versatile in
terms of the spell casting all right i
don't think we're supposed to grab that
because it looks like it's very hot
all right now maybe we can grab it
okay here we go
uh is that it
i bet we have to pull them all at the
same time
because i think there's three right
all right so that's one
that's two
and
that's three
all right harry you grab this one
and ron you take this one i was gonna be
so mad if they actually
ready started getting hot again right
when i walked away with one of them
oh man more of these guys the red caps
dude i i
recently read i say recently it's been
about a year but i read through the
dresden files
uh and for any of you who have read
dresden files man i just cannot look at
red caps the same way or hear red caps
and not think of the red cap in the
dresden files because it's just so
i don't want to ruin it for anyone who
might might read the series but yeah the
the red caps are uh
pretty intense
or the red cap i should say
yeah man if you guys grew up with harry
potter and are looking for a series that
is
a much more mature
series
but
lots of magic and lots of mystery
lots of uh
solving various mysteries and a world
that just
starts out so small
and just seems like fairly normal and
then by the time you get to like the
fourth the fourth fifth book or so
just absolute insanity in terms of how
big that world gets and it's still going
it is an ongoing series so
i highly highly recommend it if you uh
if you like i said if you grew up with
harry potter you know you're in your
mid-20s late 20s 30s early 30s now it's
it's a great series
all right so
looks like we are weak
pretty much across the board except for
harry now harry's doing
doing much better on the health meter
all right so now we need to head let's
see this way here
let's see i guess we have to have two
grab it at one time
all right and let's switch
ron
come on ron
hey hermione that space looks about the
right size for you
oh wow i actually have to switch she
doesn't just automatically okay there we
go crawl into
he won't forget about us will you
this kind of co-op gameplay makes me
wonder how that's going to work in
hogwarts legacy i know it's not going to
be
multiplayer but they've talked about
having companions
and so i wonder if they're going to be
puzzles that we have to solve that
involve
using more than one
witch or wizard where you have to hope
it's not exactly like this you know but
where you do have to get the other
person involved
all right hermione knows repairo so
i think we're gonna need to
enable that spell
yeah and they gotta figure out something
better for the spells i mean having to
constantly switch like this
really annoying
oh wow can i not repair this
what she can't repair that
dude i was gonna feel so smart i was
like this is exactly what you have to do
right walk up repair
i've been watching the hogwarts legacy
trailer too much i think maybe that's
what it is here all right wait what is
what are you locking on to down there
i have no idea
no idea what she's locking onto and it
has to be something that she can solve
on her own
i was gonna say maybe we all have to
like pull on that chain together
oh
let's see here i feel like we gotta use
that that bridge over there
maybe i just wasn't aiming it at quite
the right thing
you have to aim it like the gears or
something or perhaps walk a little bit
closer
oh my gosh dude
why is this game so obtuse or maybe i'm
obtuse
oh dude i think it's i just think it's
this old school game design
which i play i mean i grew up playing
these types of games i i remember
playing this specific game but i
definitely did not beat it because i
don't remember the buck week thing at
all so i might have rented it and played
it for like a day or something but
played through all of chamber of secrets
though that one i i played a lot
obviously the first game as well but
yeah this one i just don't don't really
have any memories of it alright so this
clearly isn't working let's try maybe
you have to freeze
i love that little voice there
nope
all right
maybe
like it's clearly oh my goodness no way
wait is all of this like walkable
dude that is crazy
i knew there was a reason i was like why
is it locking on
to seemingly nothing down here i guess
that was it was trying to get me to let
me look back here does it actually start
to melt away
does it stay looks like it stays
yeah stays okay
oh no wait i just saw some of it no no
no get back up it takes forever no
wait did i just glitch
i think we just glitched
i think we just glitched it guys
oh my goodness we totally just glitched
it
we totally just unless she can like go
through here
yep we're glitched
we are definitely glitched i really hope
there was a an auto save actually i
don't even know if this game auto saves
i don't even know if this game auto
saves this could be bad man this could
be really bad
oh no
can i switch oh i can't switch
characters either
no
i wonder what would happen if i saved
the game and then i came back in right
here
let me do this let me save over i've got
two files so i kind of alternate between
i'm gonna save over the buckbeak file
uh overwrite file
because the other one is is my more
recent file
and then we'll load back in and
hopefully
hopefully it loads us
in the right spot
i'm just gonna try a couple more things
here before i
completely quit out
oh that's really annoying dude
that's really annoying and she because
she kind of grabbed on i'm like oh it's
not melting and then all of a sudden
just everything decides to melt like
at the same time
oh so frustrating
yeah i don't see anything that's gonna
be able to get me out of this
like i wish there was a way to
if you could like i don't know freeze it
above you and then somehow jump back up
there
this is bad guys this is really bad all
right let's quit the game and then we'll
come back in
and hope that reloading somehow corrects
this because if not
oh i don't know dude i really don't want
to have to replay all that again please
work
please work
press the a button to continue
i really hope it just even if it loads
the beginning of the mission i really
won't mind at all
just do not load me at the bottom of
that little lake or pond whatever it is
oh my goodness yes
oh thank you so much i was i was worried
i was definitely worried about that
right there all right so here we go we
need to go back to arie we only need to
do this little part right here
and then switch to ron
ron grabs right there then hermione
looks about the right size crawl through
come on come on
come on hermione you can do it
wait what
this game you guys oh my gosh
some of the little like design like why
why do i have to
oh my goodness be exactly
exactly in the right spot like look at
this
okay switch quickly
hermione squeeze
crawl
oh
no she won't forget about you relax ron
alright so now we're gonna be much more
careful this time
and i'm just gonna make basically a just
go straight across
all right freeze it as much as possible
are you kidding me right now
oh my goodness we we literally almost
just messed it up right at the jump
we literally almost messed it up right
away
no
look this way hermione no not even that
way this way okay here we go all right
isn't it crazy how we almost did it
right the first time like the first time
it was almost perfect
and then i just i just had to look back
you know
i just had to say hey i wonder what's uh
if it melts
let's open this first before we grab the
this used to drive me crazy in games
where
it just did not auto detect what you
were wanting to do and the controls were
so kind of wonky
that it wouldn't line up just right
all right there we go more points and
then i saw something
over here oh wait i think that's i think
that's ron right
oh no that opened the gate for them
excellent
excellent all right come on through guys
and then let's see do i have to get them
across here too
oh i bet you do i bet you do probably
won't just let me go on
oh oh wait wait
oh i heard something oh man these guys
again
the red caps
excuse me
doxy bites are poisonous oh no
oh no oh it is right on me too
i don't think i'm gonna have time
i really need some antidote okay this is
antidote
there you go there you go there you go
take your antidote and then i've gotta
very quickly enable a wigan weld potion
for you
all right there's wigan weld
come on hermione come on
all right let's see how much does that
refill us
pretty good about what 65 70 of the way
all right we're ready now
relax hermione you only have one more
let's take this thing out first
okay there we go got him
now we're gonna take you out i need some
antidotes would you relax about the
antidote
i've been poisoned
i need something
poisoned
i've been poisoned i need antidote
well if the game would let me equip
literally more than two items
this wouldn't be so annoying
i need some antidote
all right there will you calm down
please
and now we're out of the that potion so
it did actually go into an inventory i
guess the ones that we made with snape
but it went to uh
hermione's now my question is what if we
get poisoned again
if we get poisoned again are we just out
of luck
all right we got a nice little puzzle
for us here
oh great we just
set him free and he's gonna point okay
so we're about to find out
we're gonna find out guys
we're totally gonna find out what
happens
dude these doxies are so annoying
hermione uh
hold on is it like dark souls where if i
i just refill my health can we kind of
just ride this out
can can we just keep refilling health
and and ride the poison out here
or just wait this weekend
i was hoping wigan weld was kind of like
the do-it-all potion but
i really need some antidote now
i don't have any hermione this is really
complicated
yes indeed poisoned
i need some answers dude she's just
gonna keep she's gonna keep talking
about being poisoned until she dies
she's dead man she's gonna die
okay is that literally what we're
supposed to do just destroy all of these
all right that one's gonna let another
one i think the poison were off though
by the way guys i think it did
all right i want to see if i can freeze
these guys
because that would make this a lot
easier
no you can't
i've been poisoned are you serious
one hit and he poisoned me
destroy it there we go
oh i think there's a little uh buttons
that we stand on
how do you destroy this thing without
him hitting you at least once
all right there we go
okay now we should probably go ahead and
drink one more wiggin weld but i believe
that's oh no we got four i was gonna say
i think it's the last one
all right so that will refill our health
and it seems that you can indeed just
wait it out and it will go away
eventually
eventually it will go away
i need some antidote all right can we
stand on this here
here we go
this poison's really affecting me i need
some antidotes and of course as soon as
you move
i need something i can weigh this down
with
yep you do
oh
wait a second wait a second
let's use repairo here
repair the box
and now can i push it
oh my gosh
wait we can't
wait wait
what
oh my goodness
why can't we not push these
if i do flupindo it's gonna destroy it
it just straight up destroys it
uh wait wait wait glacies maybe
all right you know what
i am really getting tired of changing
spells
x or y they're the only two buttons that
is so crazy to me
why can i not use a or something oh man
b l r just let me use more buttons than
these two
all right let's try glacius
because i feel like flopindo you got to
keep on just because it is so
necessary for just about everything
all right so we
that's gonna stop the flow of water
see there's one more over here
[Applause]
okay now can i push this thing
oh they restart again
interesting okay so you can freeze them
for a time
we can repair these guys
it doesn't seem like we can push them
it will let me get down here
no nothing
can destroy it though
we can destroy it and repair it okay can
we lock onto that guy's eye up there is
that going to be significant
i feel like that's once we get ron in
here we're going to need lumos in some
some capacity
maybe i just wasn't quick enough let's
do it quickly
and then it says dodge i don't know what
dodge isn't going to help us with this
okay they were definitely all frozen for
a time
definitely all frozen right there for at
least a moment
and it doesn't seem that anything
happened okay well let's try this let's
try to repair everything
i'm gonna repair all the boxes i don't
see why this would matter i'm gonna
actually put it on x now
all right so there's one
maybe i can hop on that one to climb up
there's two
there's three
and then four be right here
okay they're all repaired i mean i feel
like why can't i not just move that and
then move it right in there that's all
we gotta do
that's
it all right is there any way to climb
up here no
all right so all of the boxes are
repaired
now let's run around and freeze
everything
okay that's two
and three
and nothing happened
goodness dude
oh my goodness what is happening
maybe i need harry and ron maybe i need
them in here with me
can i even go back can i actually
i mean we could definitely get them in
here 100 we can get them in here because
of the uh
she just might have to use the glacious
spell again
that's probably what it is dude
okay
come on lock on to the water
or maybe it's that the uh
remember the bridge over here
no please do not fall off
whatever you do don't fall off
all right there we go
i wonder if they'll automatically follow
her if i have to like
gradually switch off of each
character and and keep freezing
come on
my goodness you guys really won't walk
over here
get up hermione come on
okay wait so how are we gonna do this
because it thaws pretty quickly look at
that
i wonder if they'll just follow me now
all right come on guys
what i can't even switch to them
ex what
okay that's weird
let me see what our mission says right
now it's probably just going to say
complete the challenge
yeah collect the carp carpe retractum
spell book
all right i don't understand why they're
not following me and hey i can't i can't
switch to them at all
oh dude
i feel like they need this right here
wait oh i thought it was
thought it was letting me repair or
something
all right well i don't guess they're
going to follow i was hoping they would
just follow me
no not that way
well we made it back over okay
oh come on please turn
they did not follow at all all right so
i guess we have to complete whatever's
in here on our own i can't think of any
other way to get them in there right now
and then maybe once we can go upstairs
and once we fix that bridge then
hopefully they'll follow
yeah i guess we're on our own for this
part
so back into the other room we go
all right fresh set of eyes here so
let's just think about this logically we
have a switch here
that we need a heavy weight on
um it seems pretty clear that one of
these
boxes
will do that for us right i mean
one of these boxes would probably be
enough we have four boxes there doesn't
seem to be any way
to move the boxes
we can lock on
if i press anything else nothing happens
uh we can also see what happens if i try
to freeze anything and we freeze
anything here
we also have the glaciers ability to
freeze the water here
uh we we've done that on all three spots
nothing whatsoever seems to happen
pretty much the only thing we have not
yet interacted with in this area is that
little
pot over there so i'm just gonna
just to make sure that we've tried
everything
in our power here in this area
i'm gonna go here blast this a couple
times yeah i figured it's probably just
gonna give us
now we did have there were pixies in
here
or not pixies doxies or whatever that
poisoned us
go ahead and blast this one too just to
be sure
[Music]
we destroyed them all
see freezing this like
does it give me something i can climb up
on
wait i don't think that was intended
i do not think that was intended
or was it
oh my goodness was that actually the
answer
or did i just break the game
no way that was actually the answer
right
okay now you're shining over there
dude i think it was i think that's
actually how you're supposed to do it
because then
i have to go over here to this one
i'm gonna freeze this one right here
and then
oh my gosh dude
that is so weird i cannot believe that's
actually what you're supposed to do
maybe one more turn
nice
nice right into the eye and what does
that do
ah that's gonna freeze a block for us
so it is absolutely nothing to do with
the
wait
okay i was about to say so we probably
have to destroy this now right yeah
and then can we slide this one there we
go
she's not strong enough to push the uh
rickety crate but this large block of
ice
oh hermione's got that piece of cake
here
oh you know what though it's it's a
puzzle too we can't do it this way
we cannot do it this way we've gotta go
the other way
we gotta go here
gotta go back here
destroy you
oh come on here we go
and push it back
this way right here
oh wait let's just destroy this while
we're at it
oh no wait a second
wait a second
we want to get it
we want to get it exactly right here but
hold on if we repair
this if we don't repair then we push it
back and it's gonna
oh tricky one here tricky one here
yeah that one i feel like has to stay we
want to get it we want to get it exactly
right here and then we just push it over
maybe i'm wrong about the exact
positioning of it let's see
let's go ahead and switch back
back to repair
let's repair it nope i was not wrong so
wow what am i missing here
because if i push it right here it's
gonna go all the way
oh my gosh you guys what
and there's no way i don't think there's
any way to move these things
if i could push this it would be simple
but i can't i can't push this
i can only repair it
and let's see can i create another block
of ice
dude wait maybe that's what you have to
do
i wonder if we shine the lights again
will it create the ice again
i don't even think that's an option
though actually
we'll try though we'll try
oh dude it is uh
oh my gosh this game is so sneaky man
wait no no no it did i don't think it
i don't think it generated another block
of ice though
let's see if we go
back to repair
all right we'll repair this right here
yeah it's like it's just it's in the
perfectly
bad spot
i mean i don't think that stops it does
it like if i
nope
oh my gosh dude
and then eventually the light just
wait
oh i thought i heard like
that is interesting though that it
that it made that noise again and that
the light comes back out so like i
wonder if i can maybe i need to flip
this guy around
dude this puzzle
it's either super simple
or way more challenging than a puzzle in
this game should be
and i i could just be completely
overlooking it here's what i'm gonna try
i'm gonna try and see if i can go up to
the statue here
and if they're i want to see if there's
a way to turn this around no
darn it i was hoping there was a way to
turn this around and like maybe there
was another eye on the other side or
something
that then you could get another block of
ice but
okay that shines
that shines
yep go ahead drop down drop down
drop down hermione it's all good you're
not gonna be hurt from that short
distance
okay wait we can still move this though
but i don't think we can move it
yep we cannot move it again i'm just
gonna say let go
doesn't seem like there's any
interaction that we can do with that
oh my gosh man i feel like i'm just
missing something i feel like i'm
missing something incredibly obvious
but if i could get another block of ice
then we could do this easily right
what am i missing here you guys
hold on let's see if i if i do uh
okay wait
oh my gosh i figured it out i'm so dumb
oh my goodness i should have stuck with
what i was doing the first time i would
have been much closer
okay yep
wow
all right we gotta switch back to
repairo
see i was overthinking it because i was
like oh no i'm gonna be smart you gotta
you gotta bring it in from this side
and you do
but
but
you can send it back the other way
all right come on
dude i was really gonna i was trying
everything i was at a loss
i was at a complete loss all right so
now what we do is we repair this one
yes now it's in the perfect spot
oh but wait
but wait
one last tricky piece here
have to destroy that one now give it a
shove back
and then finally ladies and gentlemen
here we go we send the block it holds it
down and there we go it's unlocked
we can move on
yes it was hermione
yes it was oh my gosh dude i'm just not
used to puzzles like that in games in a
while
that are that sort of uh
i mean
it's not hard it's really not that hard
but
i guess i was just overthinking it
that's probably what was happening you
guys were probably screaming the answer
long before i solved it but it's all
good oh man more of these guys
no i don't want your stink bomb or
whatever that thing is
yeah i don't use the dodge mechanic at
all i know they put it in the game but
i don't use it at all i just stand and
spam and hope that i have enough uh
health to last
all right now i believe we're gonna be
opening we're gonna be um like up top
now right
yes there we are okay
so now hopefully we should be able to
get harry and ron up here with us
right maybe maybe maybe
not okay do we repair this i'm just
gonna go ahead and switch to repair now
because i feel like it's
definitely gonna be needed here
okay that was kind of weird the
animation but i think it worked
i think it worked
no
oh my gosh okay good
it actually worked that time though it
didn't glitch me out again and keep me
down there
okay what in the world guys
here we go
keep lowering it one more maybe one more
there we go nice
and this has been quite an elaborate
puzzle here this whole room
and it looks like it keeps going up
keeps going up and up and up all right
let's hit this oh there's a chest though
right here
can never pass up the chance at a wizard
card
looks like another quidditch symbol on
that one
not gonna tell me who it was
yeah see that's a i wish there was an
easier way to
instantly see which wizard card i got
i guess if i could remember all the
because i know we were already done with
quidditch so we completed that one
we got the mountain troll there in the
beasts category or classical beasts
category rather which wizards do we have
only one edgar stroller
inventor of the sneaker scope and then
vampires we have sir herbert varney
that was a rather uh
creepy vampire at that morgan le fay
queen maeve ignacia wildsmith beatrix
bloxham
gun hilda of course more and then oh
wait
yeah in the face though
the first one there okay so yeah i don't
know
i don't know if one of those was new or
not
because it doesn't give me any
indication
all right so let's go ahead and press
the button here
there we go
all right harry and ron
come on up my friends
finally it's about time
all right so
back over here now
and this way
okay what now
okay we can totally switch to harry and
ron now
because they can't walk themselves we
have to manually tell them
all right boys here you go
all right we should be able to regroup
everybody together now
yes all right nicely done
oh and there's a little uh
bot up there
now harry's the one who can jump across
gaps but i don't think he can jump
across that gap
i do not think he can jump that far no i
do not
that's probably totally what you're
supposed to do right
all right we got something up above
there we've got what looks like some
sort of
greenish vines here
okay hermione's still there
okay wait hold on is there a spot over
there that i missed
i go back across here
oh this is where hermione was right yeah
okay ron is the one who can like get the
secret passages but
this doesn't strike me as the need of a
secret passage right here to be honest
like are we supposed to cut those maybe
i'm trying to i'm kind of looking to see
what we can lock onto
and there's not a lot let me tell you
i'm not seeing anything that we can lock
onto actually
all right let's try to make this jump
yep that's what i was afraid of
that's what i was afraid of he cannot
make the jump
all right ron
your turn buddy your turn and you know
what we might as well go ahead and uh
go ahead and give him a wig and well
potion
oh wait that's hermione i want to stay
on ron because he definitely needs a
potion here
all right got his health back
all right ron we need you to find a
secret passage bud
find us
a secret passage because i have no idea
what to do here
unless we're just supposed to go back in
here but
nope negative on that
i mean is it are we supposed to use this
again maybe
keep going higher up
yeah that actually never made us go high
up in the first place it was this right
here it just lowered these
yeah i cannot lock on to any of this
not locking on not locking on
not locking on all right guys you know
what i'm gonna have to sleep on this one
it's getting pretty late and i am just
kind of stumped right now so
we'll put a pin in this one we'll put a
bookmark i promise it will not be as
long between the next episode i really
do want to play at least a couple more
of the harry potter games before
hogwarts legacy comes out so i don't
know maybe we're about halfway through
prisoner of azkaban right now i have no
idea there could be a lot more but we
definitely want to finish prisoner of
azkaban and then get to maybe the uh the
bad games as well goblet of fire i'd
love to be able to get through order of
the phoenix order the phoenix i remember
as being one of the best in terms of at
least building out hogwarts castle it
did get a little repetitive but i would
love to be able to get through that one
we'll just kind of have to see how it
goes uh but yeah next time we'll pick
back up here and see if we can figure
out whoa almost just fell off as ron
right there uh but yeah we'll see if we
can figure out where to go from here as
always thank you all so much for
watching if you all enjoyed this video
then make sure to give it a thumbs up
that's gonna help more people find the
video
thank you all so much for watching once
again and i will talk to you again soon